[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález un nuevo ataque
terrorista en ruta a francia tres
personas murieron en la ciudad de niza
en el sur del país después de ser
atacadas por un sujeto que
posteriormente fue detenido por la
policía local los hechos tuvieron lugar
en la basílica de notre damme de la
ciudad de niza en el sur del país y el
ataque ha sido rechazado desde
diferentes frentes a nivel internacional
no es la primera vez que niza y que
francia son blanco de este tipo de
ataques hace cuatro años justamente esta
misma ciudad en el corazón de la riviera
francesa en el mediterráneo' fue
escenario de un ataque yihadista que
dejó 86 víctimas recapitulemos en el
siguiente reportaje
el apuñalamiento en niza es el último de
una serie de ataques terroristas en
francia en enero de 2015 12 personas
murieron en un ataque a la revista
satírica charlie hebdo la revista se
convirtió en un objetivo después de la
publicación de polémicas caricaturas que
representaban al profeta mahoma el
ataque fue seguido el asesinato de una
mujer policía en servicio en el suburbio
parisino de monjas y al día siguiente
cuatro personas murieron tras ser
tomadas como rehenes en un supermercado
coches de la capital francesa en
noviembre de ese año una serie de
ataques coordinados en todo parís matar
más 130 personas incluidos 90 en el
teatro bataclán el grupo estado islámico
se atribuyó la responsabilidad de estos
atentados esa organización también
afirmó estar detrás de la masacre del
día de la bastilla inicia en 2016 86
personas murieron y cientos más
resultaron heridas después de que un
hombre condujera un camión hacia la
multitud reunida para ver un espectáculo
de fuegos artificiales en 2018 cinco
personas murieron en el mercado de
navideño de estrasburgo y el año pasado
cuatro personas murieron a puñaladas en
la sede de la policía de parís en
septiembre de este año charlie hebdo
volvió a ser noticia mundial cuando
volvió a publicar las caricaturas de
mahoma el día en que comenzó el juicio
de 14 personas acusadas de ser cómplices
de estos atentados en enero de 2015 más
tarde ese mes las antiguas oficinas de
la revista fueron nuevamente atacadas ya
que un hombre armado con un cuchillo
hirió a dos periodistas que creía que el
personal de charlie hebdo todavía estaba
trabajando allí el 16 de octubre el
profesor samuel para ti fue asesinado en
un suburbio de parís después de haber
mostrado a sus alumnos las caricaturas
de charlie hebdo durante una clase sobre
libertad de expresión
sobre este tema el presidente francés
emmanuel lemma convocó a una reunión de
emergencia para determinar los pasos a
seguir para garantizar la seguridad en
la ciudad de niza en la ciudad de parís
así como en otros lugares sensibles del
territorio francés estas fueron sus
palabras en francia no hay una comunidad
es la comunidad nacional le quiero decir
a todos nuestros conciudadanos sin
importar su religión si creen o no creen
en este momento debemos unirnos y no
ceder ante el espíritu de división junio
y no vayan sede al distrito de decisión
igualmente varios países árabes han
rechazado este ataque en la ciudad de
niza entre ellos están arabia saudita
egipto los emiratos árabes unidos y
jordania ellos consideraron
enérgicamente que estos hechos eran
completamente reprochables otros estados
musulmanes como turquía país con elche
francia recién recientemente ha tenido
un cruce verbal de acusaciones y
señalamientos también rechazo este
ataque lo hizo a través de un comunicado
de prensa que fue emitido por el
ministro
y de relaciones exteriores turco en la
ciudad de ankara
fuertemente condenamos el ataque
perpetrado hoy en la basílica de notre
damme en niza francia no hay razón que
justifique la muerte de personas o
justifique la violencia es obvio que
quienes llevaron a cabo este ataque
brutal en un lugar de culto sagrado
nunca se ha beneficiado de los valores
religiosos humanos y morales para
analizar este tema aquí en el debate de
france 24 hemos invitado a pilar
martínez va a ser ella es licenciada en
historia contemporánea y en philosophie
lo lo he afrontado bien es doctora en
ciencias políticas y catedrática de
historia y civilización de la españa
contemporánea también se une a este
debate desde la ciudad de madrid en
españa
el señor isidro sepúlveda analista
internacional especialista en
geopolítica terrorismo y crímenes de
odio además es profesor de historia
contemporánea ustedes también pueden ser
parte de este debate a través de las
redes sociales en la recuerdo france24
bajo ese arroba sant y luego mi cuenta
personal deje los comentarios con el
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todas
sus preguntas y sus comentarios quiero
comenzar entonces
de apilar en la ciudad de nantes en
francia y cómo entender este escenario
en el que está francia en este momento
vemos a varias víctimas a lo largo de
las últimas semanas a raíz de varios
atentados o ataques terroristas y vemos
también discrepancias señalamientos
acusaciones entre el presidente manuel
marco con algunos líderes de países
musulmanes principalmente con el
presidente de turquía recep tayib
erdogán
en primer lugar buenas noches a todos
desde la ciudad de nantes en el oeste de
francia como decía en la presentación
soy historiadora y los historiadores
siempre nos escudamos en la idea de que
nuestro trabajo es sobre el pasado y
este y nos encontramos siempre incómodos
para reaccionar en directo y en un
momento en que verdaderamente en el país
se vive yo creo un doble problema el
problema sanitario porque hoy empieza el
confinamiento de toda la población a la
noche y ese atentado brutal esta mañana
que se suma a un atentado que nos tocó
muy muy de cerca no solamente por ser
historiadores en la decapitación de un
terror de historia geografía hace dos
semanas es decir que es un cúmulo de
circunstancias de acontecimientos
etcétera ante los cuales la reacción es
como ciudadana un primero
hispano-francesa y como historiadora
este es difícil de poder englobar todos
estos acontecimientos y dar una
explicación porque el problema
fundamental yo diría es en la oposición
entre la libertad de expresión y la
defensa de esta libertad de expresión
que francia pasa por el concepto de ley
gira y evidentemente el respeto que
debería para una comunidad muy
importante en francia la islámica el
respeto que una parte de la población
debería a esa religión entonces yo creo
que el debate es este es muy importante
y es un debate que atraviesa toda la
sociedad
no solamente desde el punto de vista
religioso chino yo diría también social
generacional etc
saliendo acaba de publicar esta última
caricatura en la cual evidentemente
bromea con el presidente turco
representando la fundadora de una manera
evidentemente jocosa pero la cuestión es
hoy hay que tenemos derecho a reír de
todo a las que más bien hay que
autocensurarse para preservar la villa
simplemente lanzó este debate porque
desgraciadamente años de poesía
muchas aristas para tener en cuenta en
torno a este tema vamos a conocer la
opinión de isidro nuestro otro invitado
en la ciudad de madrid en la repito la
pregunta isidro cómo entender este
escenario entonces en el que se
encuentra francia ya lo decíamos estos
hechos de las últimas semanas estos
últimos ataques
en los comentarios que van y vienen
entre ankara y parís también entre los
dos mandatarios como entender qué es lo
que está pasando entre francia y el
mundo musulmán
bueno en realidad para entenderlo mejor
hay que descomponerlo son cosas
completamente distintas y unidas por
como siempre ocurren a lo largo de la
historia por canales en ocasiones
demasiado sangrientos en primer lugar
nos encontramos con una geopolítica
cambiante y en la que tanto francia como
turquía quieren seguir significando y se
empiezan fundamentales para la
resolución de distintos conflictos en
segundo lugar nos encontramos con una
crisis general una pandemia que ha
puesto patas arriba toda la legitimidad
de los gobiernos y están todos puestos
en cuestión incluyendo por supuesto
también al turco en tercer lugar nos
encontramos con una defensa de la
libertad de expresión que choca de
alguna forma en este caso brutal con la
libertad religiosa y el respeto que
merecen
a todas las creencias religiosas y por
último de lo que estamos hablando hoy
que es de la utilización de medios
violentos para alcanzar cualquier tipo
de notoriedad para alcanzar cualquier
realizar cualquier tipo de protesta
política
esto último es claramente condenables y
por supuesto no creo que haya
absolutamente nadie que no pueda
defender salvo a aquellos que están
dentro de la misma dirección política
ideológica y fundamentalista en todos
los demás aspectos lo que hay es una
confrontación clara y una búsqueda de
intereses tanto por parte de francia
como por parte no solamente de turquía
sixtina sino de buena parte del mundo
islámico y solamente hablar de libia y
hablar de silla y vemos que son dos
grandes espinas por no hablar también de
irán dos grandes espinas en el que hay
una confrontación entre lo que está
haciendo francia y lo que están haciendo
otras potencias europeas pero también
enfrentados
el gran gendarme que quiere levantarse
como líder del mundo musulmán que es
erdogán y de turquía y si lo sigo con
ustedes ya retomó con este pilar para
preguntarle un detalle histórico e
isidro a lo largo de esta semana hemos
empezado a ir una serie de conceptos y
de acusaciones ya lo estábamos
mencionando entre parís y ancares varios
países del golfo pérsico y un poco más
allá por ejemplo el primer ministro de
pakistán e imran khan acusó al
presidente manuel marco de estar
impulsando o promoviendo la islamofobia
desde su punto de vista
usted lo siente así siente que esta
política del presidente manuel marco de
atacar este extremismo islámico este
separatismo islámico como lo han
catalogado allí está fortaleciendo esta
islamofobia a nivel internacional
lo que estaba fortaleciendo es la
reacción contraria a la ley llama fobia
en muchos países musulmanes a aquellos
países que estaban dudando entre
definitivamente condenar algunos
movimientos radicales fundamentalmente
vinculados al wahabismo con la reacción
visceral republicana del presidente
macro lo que han hecho es decantarse por
el consentimiento decantarse por las
simpatías o natillas y versiones más
radicales del islam que utilizan
cualquier medio para conseguir sus fines
yo creo que en el mundo occidental no
hay debate en el mundo occidental
claramente apostamos por por a por la
libertad de expresión incluso cuando es
hiriente e incluso cuando es molesta
incluso cuando el blasfema esto no
ocurre en el mundo islámico no ocurre en
otras culturas y estamos en un mundo
globalizado ser una una revista satírica
que tienen realmente muy poca tirada en
en francia tiene repercusiones en
globales y desde luego tenemos que que
contrabalancear cuál es nuestro nivel de
aceptación por parte de unos criterios
por parte de aquellos que defienden una
libertad de expresión radical y aquellos
que lo que quieren literalmente es
cortar cualquier tipo de libertad de
expresión pilar ha hablado de
autocensura yo no hablaría como tal pero
sí de contención y de una palabra que
más allá de la libertad de expresión
pero como base fundamental de la
convivencia tenemos que volver a
utilizar de una forma prolija que es
respeto respeto y tolerancia pilar para
ponernos en contexto para los
televidentes en américa latina'
y usted me corregirá en torno a las
cifras ya lo que voy a decir francia
tiene una estrecha relación con el mundo
musulmán cerca de 6 millones de
musulmanes residen en este país europeo
algunos de ellos ya son segunda y
tercera generación de inmigrantes que
han llegado principalmente de argelia
marruecos y de túnez entre otros países
del norte de áfrica como ha sido la
relación entre francia y el mundo
musulmán dada ese estrecho pasado
colonial que tienen estos países
y yo simplemente quería hacer una
puntualización a la que acaba de decir
mi compañero sobre el término
autocensura es el dibujante de lemon del
plancha el que se expresó de esta manera
cuando se ha unido reiteró en la
publicación de todas las caricaturas
sobre el profeta etcétera bueno es
verdad que la situación de francia con
evidentemente esos 6 millones de
musulmanes que provienen de diferentes
países es una situación complicada y
evidentemente en un momento de atentados
tenemos tendencia a olvidarlo es yo creo
que durante estos últimos 20 años no se
ha producido en los barrios de las
periferias de las grandes ciudades sobre
todo en la región parisina una
integración de estas comunidades es
decir
se habla en francia de comunitarismo es
decir evidentemente de agrupaciones de
las diferentes nacionalidades pero que
tienen en común una religión en en estos
lugares en los cuales la integración en
la sociedad es cada vez más difícil el
acceso a los estudios también y esta
separación que hay entre entre las dos
comunidades la comunidad
digamos francesa pero los demás los
musulmanes lo son también es decir que
yo creo que también aquí estamos también
ahondando en un programa muy muy
importante que es la cuestión
identitaria es decir que es ser francés
es la lengua es la cultura y aquí
estamos hablando de un choque de
culturas es la condición y lo que
sabemos evidentemente que yo creo que
las cifras han salido hoy más del 75 por
ciento
los musulmanes entre comillas que viven
en estos barrios considera que la ley
musulmana es muy superior a la vida de
la república yo diría para terminar
marcar esta especie de foso que hay
entre las dos comunidades yo creo que
hay algo que para los que no somos de
identidad francesa que hemos llegado
posteriormente es muy sorprendente es la
expresión la utilización recurrente por
parte de todas las fuerzas políticas
francesas del respeto de la república de
los valores de la república etcétera el
concepto de república es algo que para
los personas de fuera incluso para mí en
que soy
evidentemente de un país vecino es algo
que chirría y todavía más en esas
comunidades que se ven totalmente más
finales pero hay que decir pilar que
este tipo de ataques y también ha sido
criticado por diferentes sectores en
países musulmanes y en los países árabes
en el golfo que este tipo de ataques no
representan a los musulmanes hay que
hacer esa claridad esto no representa a
los seguidores de la religión islámica
presenta esos valores pero a la vez ve
uno la otra cara de la moneda y sale el
presidente macro na los medios de
comunicación a decir que francia está en
el punto de mira precisamente porque
defiende los valores y por su gusto por
la libertad y la igualdad que son los
valores fundamentales de la república
francesa son completamente incompatibles
entonces
yo veo que es decir que aquí hay un
problema en el sentido cultural profunda
de la cultura yo pienso que son dos
debates paralelos cuando hoy hablaba
macro no lo el otro día por ejemplo
después de la decapitación del profesor
de historia de gracia historia de un
instituto de un colegio por haber
mostrado las caricaturas en cifras yo
creo que hay una diferencia importante y
sobre todos los debates que ha habido
estos dos días en esta próxima despertar
al principio hubo una gran unanimidad y
la comunidad musulmana los imanes de
algunas mezquitas moderados etc todos
ellos evidentemente condenados sin
paliativos
esta violencia progresivamente se ha
introducido un pero diciendo sí por
supuesto
hay que respetar la libertad de
expresión pero no tenía que haber
nuestros candidaturas pero se lo había
buscado pero etcétera pero todo esto no
es únicamente propio de la comunidad
musulmana en la comunidad de intelectual
francesa hay toda una serie de partidos
de ideologías de asociaciones etcétera
que han puesto en tela de juicio está
este esta defensa de enseñar libremente
yo dije en mi pequeña experiencia cuando
hablasen a los pocos días volví a mi
clase de historia contemporánea en la
universidad
hice una pequeña referencia a este
acontecimiento y me di cuenta que entre
los alumnos de tercer curso de
universidad mayor había muy pocos hijos
de musulmanes hay tres o cuatro chicas
con velo había
a cierta información una gran índice
es decir que yo creo que ha habido un
cambio generacional en relación con este
concepto de libertad de expresión y
quizás sería más el ir a un respeto de
todas las adicciones frente a esta idea
que no es la de tratar de elegir a
isidro viendo un poco más en detalle los
hechos recientes en francia vemos tal
vez un patrón en los últimos ataques que
han tenido lugar en este país europeo en
la mayoría de los atacantes no son
descendientes de inmigrantes que ya
llevaban varios años viviendo en francia
o que incluso nacieron en francia pero
crecieron en familias musulmanas
respetando sus tradiciones son personas
que vienen de pakistán de chechenia y en
el ataque de hoy de tunisia
recientemente habían llegado al país y
estaban en un proceso digamos de
solución de su estatus migratorio y en
un proceso de adaptación cultural e
incluso el atacante procedente de
pakistán tenía antecedentes en su país
por haber
he rechazado y criticado abiertamente
manifestaciones al gobierno francés y al
mundo occidental y vemos aquí entonces
un nuevo patrón en este tipo de ataques
es completamente distinto lo que
habíamos visto anteriormente por ser
personas que recientemente están
llegando al país y tal vez no tienen muy
claro cómo funciona un país occidental
donde hay ciertos valores y libertades
que en sus territorios no hay
bueno aquí abrimos el debate sobre los
límites de la inmigración las
capacidades de absorción de la comunidad
de acogida las los límites que hay que
poner en el proceso de integración y
desde luego los límites de los cuerpos y
fuerzas de seguridad del estado en
vigilar aquellos procesos de
radicalización que se producen de los
que vienen de fuera
pero también de los que de los que hay
dentro el problema de los cuerpos de
seguridad fundamentalmente está en los
lobos solitarios en los grupos
organizados están están monitorizados se
les puede hacer un seguimiento y se les
puede detener de hecho lo que acaba de
hacer pero después del asesinato del
profesor de historia
el presidente macro es decir es muy
claramente que va a por ellos que el
miedo
va a cambiar de bando
pero no ocurre lo mismo con los lobos
solitarios los lobos solitarios no se
tiene noticia de ellos o han expresado
de una forma muy circunstancial su
oposición a la a distintos
acontecimientos o incluso a la propia
civilización en la idea de republicana
pero no se puede hacer un seguimiento de
los miles que hay circulando en la
republica de esto se aprovecha la
reivindicación es a posteriori como hizo
el estado islámico anteriormente incluso
es posible que reclame la autoría de
estos de estos nuevos atentados es a
posteriori que en realidad son
individuos que se han radicalizado y que
han en los últimos meses y sobre todo
que responden a una falsa de una falta
de expectativa de cumplimiento de la
misión y esto es prácticamente imposible
de parar por desgracia isidro retomando
algunas de las palabras que nos decía
apilar desde la ciudad de nantes
ella nos mencionaba que ha notado que
falta un poco más de integración en los
últimos años por parte de las personas
que son migrantes que viven en su
mayoría en los barrios de la periferia
de las grandes ciudades tal vez el
problema radica en ese proceso de
adaptación cultural y en esos procesos
de integración de los extranjeros que
llegan a vivir a francia como ya
decíamos la mayoría de ellos pueden
provenir pueden llegar de países que
fueron colonias francesas sobre todo en
el norte de áfrica porque caso contrario
lo vemos en otros países europeos donde
hay una alta llegada de migrantes por
ejemplo en el caso de suecia de
finlandia donde los procesos de
integración son en un porcentaje un poco
más exitosos digámoslo así si se compara
con el caso francés
no hay un modelo único de integración y
de adaptación y desde luego no podemos
decir que un modelo es mejor que otro en
un los países funciona mejor que en
otros pero occidente en la inmensa mayor
parte de los procesos de integración
fundamentalmente de los de los
inmigrantes provenientes de países
musulmanes está fracasando y esto no
solamente está comprometiendo la
capacidad de adaptación de los que están
recién llegados sino que incluso se está
perdiendo la oficialización de las
generaciones que ya han nacido en los
países de acogida en concreto en francia
ahí es cierto que los últimos atentados
han estado bajo autoridades recién
llegados pero hay muchos yihadistas
radicalizado
que son de segunda y de tercera
generación que han sido educados en las
que en los institutos e incluso en las
universidades francesas
de lo que se ha producido a lo largo de
los últimos años fundamentalmente a lo
largo de las últimas dos décadas es la
generación populista de unas creencias
que anteriormente estaban segregadas y
eran casi la calificadas de anti
modernidad el crecimiento en las
capacidades de adoctrinamiento por parte
de confesiones vinculadas al wahabismo y
la proliferación de anti ejemplos del
maltrato de las guerras de afganistán y
de irán
el fracaso de la primavera árabe tiene
su repercusión en la radicalización de
generaciones que teóricamente deberían
ya estar educadas y ser fieles a la
democracia occidental y a la república
francesa
pilar usted reside ya lo decíamos en la
ciudad de nantes en francia usted como
ciudadana de este país que ha estado
siguiendo los acontecimientos recientes
que han tenido lugar como
y se reciente como está sacudiendo esto
a la sociedad francesa este tipo de
acontecimientos como lo decía usted en
el marco de esta emergencia sanitaria y
de esta nueva de esta nueva orden de
confinamiento que está por comenzar en
ese país
claro en el contexto sanitario y la
sucesión de este tipo de violencias de
quita todo para distanciarse de mira
para abordar el tema pero lo que he
visto antes de conectarme con todos
ustedes es que evidentemente dentro de
la clase política
hay también una yo diría una guerra o
una oposición entre la derecha y la
extrema derecha una gran rivalidad para
evidentemente hacerse con ese electorado
que queda un poco desubicado con esa
victoria de majón que representaba un
centroderecha etcétera que las
declaraciones hoy realizan entre la
realeza y los nuevos posibles líderes de
la derecha republicana y denostando y
criticando
la debilidad del gobierno de macrón
entró en su lucha contra las migraciones
es decir que yo creo que este debate se
va a volver a replantear estaba un poco
largado con el tema del problema
sanitario pero es curioso que hoy los
líderes de la derecha extrema derecha
realicen este tipo de lectura del
atentado para que yo creo que de la
misma manera que decía mi compañero en
esta rivalidad puede hacerse con el
liderazgo a nivel geopolítico estamos no
muy lejos de las personas elecciones no
hay ningún líder político en la
izquierda progresista para realmente
representar ese a esa visión de la
defensa de valores de laicidad y de
consenso y de integración y yo creo que
va a haber realmente en estos momentos
ese debate de política interior que está
alarmado pero que es fundamental la vida
política francesa es la grecia el tema
no ha podido evitar ser politizado
incluso
algunos medios de comunicación de países
árabes han dicho que este choque
continuado que se le ha presentado al
presidente macro contra los intereses
del mundo islámico
le funcionan a su favor en un intento
por ganar votos de la extrema derecha
todo esto de cara a esas elecciones
presidenciales que son solamente en 15
meses en el febrero del 2022
que piensa usted de esto y le hago esa
misma pregunta isidro y ya me quedan
pocos minutos para finalizar entonces
les digo que sean puntuales por favor
a isidro a mí
adelante isidro entonces y luego vamos
con las conclusiones pilar
si simplemente indica que en la política
actual de 15 meses es mucho tiempo y por
tanto tomar posición ahora sobre asuntos
de tanto calado y de tanta repercusión y
sobre todo de tanta transcendencia
histórica como es el tema de la
inmigración y sobre todo todo el tema de
la integración de las nuevas de los de
los nuevos inmigrantes las nuevas
sociedades inmigrantes no creo que le
aporte en este momento ni dentro de 15
meses muchos votos a marc actuarán así
que va a haber una rivalidad entre la
derecha y la extrema derecha pero yo
apuesto por el sentido común el que
siempre han tenido los franceses
sabiendo elegir a sus líderes y desde
luego
apuesto porque francia sea un bastión de
resistencia frente al avance de
percepciones de derecha radical por no
llamarlo de extrema derecha que sobre
todo en la europa del este van en camino
de imponerse en las urnas pilar para el
cierre del programa que cree usted que
viene para las próximas semanas en
francia en el marco de este
confinamiento y en estas tensiones que
se están presentando en el país que
puede suceder
pues es verdad que nosotros estamos más
situados no para hablar del futuro
y todo es totalmente inesperado porque
hace 15 días estaba ya aquí mismo
hablando con una radio argentina sobre
el asesinato este profesor no puede
imaginar que 15 días después volveríamos
a hablar de este mismo tema y yo creo
que no sé lo que puede pasar yo pienso
que en este momento todas las ciudades
están con una política evidentemente de
prevención de posibles atentados y lo
que yo he sentido en el poco rato
prestado descoció nada porque acá parte
de ahora espiritualmente confinada es
que hay una desconfianza increíble hacia
todo aquel que es diferente el modelo
blanco europeo entonces hablo del
tranvía es decir que hay esas miradas de
esos mayos de miedo que en cualquier
momento puede haber un atentado y como
decía mi compañero evidentemente
este tipo del lobo solitario el que es
muy difícil de controlar y el que crea
inseguridad suplementaria porque hacía
falta otra inseguridad si isidro
rápidamente para la conclusión treinta
segundos bueno primero mi solidaridad
con el pueblo francés con la república
francesa el apoyo a los principios
republicanos de la identidad y desde
luego en la defensa de la comprensión de
la tolerancia y del respeto mutuo por
todas las partes y aquel que vaya a un
lugar lo primero tiene que hacer es
respetar la regla arte ese lugar pues
ahí teníamos a pilar martínez va a ser
ya isidro sepúlveda muchas gracias por
compartir con nosotros sus puntos de
vista en torno a este tema ustedes
muchas gracias por la sintonía y les
recuerdo que pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios y todas sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
nuestra programación
[Música]